[موسيقى]
مساء الخير مشاهدي العربيه واهلا بكم الى
التاسعه مع ليلى الاختيار استهل هذا ابرز
العناوين
بعد فرز نحو 60% من الاصوات كالجدار اوغلو
يؤكد تقدمه في انتخابات تركيا والحزب
الحاكم ينفي
وهيئه الانتخابات تطمئن المنافسين التصويت
دون تسجيل اي مشاكل والفرز يتم بدقه
تاكيدات ايرانيه جديده على اعاده العلاقات
بين القاهره وطهران وحديث عن لقاء قريب
بين السيسي ورئيسي
[موسيقى]
بعد اتحاد الجنود الروس من المعارك موسكو
تقرب مقتل قائدين لها في بخموت
[موسيقى]
اظهرت نتائج الاوليه للانتخابات الرئاسيه
في تركيا تقدم الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان على
منافسه من مرشح تحالف المعارضه كمال
كلتشدار اوغلو وذلك بعد فرز نحو 60% من
الانتخابات وذكر التلفزيون التركيه ان
اردوغان حصل على 51% من الاصوات مقابل 42
بالمئه فقط لاووجلو في نتائج الاوليه طبعا
كانت جار اوغلو اعلن قبل قليل تقدمها عبر
تويتر فيما نفى الحزب الحاكم بقياده
اردوغان هذا التقدم
[موسيقى]
هذا هو اغلقت مكاتب الاقتراع البالغ عددها
نحو 200 الف في تركيا وسط ترقب المواطنين
الاتراك لنتائج الاوليه للانتخابات التي
سيتم عرضها مساء اليوم جاء الاغلاق بعدما
استقبلت مكاتب الاقتراح وشودا من الناخبين
منذ ساعات الصباح الاولى دون تسجيل حوادث
تذكر خلال عمليه انتخاب الرئيس الثالث عشر
للجمهوريه التركيه وتجديد اعضاء البرلمان
[موسيقى]
صباح رئيس بلديه اسطنبول والمرشح لمنصب
نائب الرئيس اكرم امام اوغلو بان البيانات
الحاليه تظهر
انجلوس يكون الرئيس حيث طالب رئيس بلديه
اسطنبول المنتمي للمعارضه الاتراك بعدم
متابعه نتائج الانتخابات من وكاله
الاناضول التابعه للدوله
قالت نائبه حزب العداله والتنميه عن مدينه
اسطنبول في لقاء مع العربيه ان الحزب الذي
ينتمي اليه والتي كانت من مؤسسيه سيحترم
نتائج الاقتراع مهما كانت كما اشارت الى
نسبه مشاركه الشباب العاليه في هذه
الانتخابات
الشباب يشاركون بقوه حزبنا سعى بشده
لاستيعاب الشباب من خلال ترشيحهم كنواب
ايضا كان لدينا حمله قويه ارى ان الجيل
الشاب ليس بعيدا عن التصويت بل هو جيل نشط
النتيجه الديمقراطيه نحترمها وبشده بل هي
تاجر على رؤوسنا عام 2019 استخدمنا حقنا
في الاعتراض على نتائج الانتخابات وهذا
طبيعي جدا سنسلم الحكم لمن يختاره الشعب
بدون ادنى تردد
عقب اغلاق صناديق الاقتراع وبدا عمليات
فرز الاصوات قال الرئيس التركيه اردوغان
ان عمليه التصويت تمت بما يليق
بالديمقراطيه في تركيا واضاف ان الوقت حان
للتشبث بصناديق الاقتراع والاستمرار في
حمايه اراده الشعب حتى صدور النتائج
النهائيه
اما خصم
اردوغانو فدعى ايضا انصاره بعدم ترك
صناديق الاقتراع حتى يتم تسليم اخر تقرير
صندوق اقتراع موقع على حد وصفه هذا وجاءت
تصريحات اوغلو فورا اغلاق صناديق الاقتراع
في الانتخابات التي شهدت اقبالا كثيفا
من جانبه اكد نائب الرئيس التركي فؤاد
عطاي بان حزب العداله والتنميه سيحترم
نتائج الانتخابات ايا كانت واضاف ان
الاقبال على التصويت في الانتخابات
الرئاسيه التركيه كثيف جدا مشيرا الى ان
هدف حزب العداله والتنميه ان تكون هذه
الانتخابات نزيهه وشفافه
صوتت لمرشح يمكنه ان يجلب الديمقراطيه
والحداثه والتعليم الى البلاد ويمنح شعبنا
طعم الحريه اولئك الذين يستمعون الى هذا
يمكنهم بالفعل تخمين من هو
جئت للتصويت اعتقد ان الاقبال سيكون
مرتفعا الشخص الذي سيفوز في الانتخابات
سيفوز بفارق ثلاث او اربع نقاط
العام مهم جدا السنوات السابقه كانت ايضا
مهمه جدا ولكن الان نحن كشعب سئمنا من بعض
الاشياء لا اريد الخوض في هذه القضايا لكن
هناك مشاكل باقتصاد البلد واشياء كثيره
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
مشاهدينا لنقل الصوره من تركيا ينضم الينا
شبكه مراسله للعربيه من اسطنبول العربيه
كريستيان بيسري من انقره مراسل عربيه
زيدان زنكلو ومن غازي عنتاب موفد العربيه
عبد القادر خربوش سابدا معك كريستيانو حتى
الساعه الارقام تشير الى تقدم اوغلو على
اردوغان كيف هي الصوره من هناك وما هي اخر
التحديثات لو سمحتي
هذه الارقام التي تشير الى تقدم كريستار
اوبلو على اردوغان هي نسبيه وبحسب الوكاله
التي تنقل عنها هذه النتائج نحن متواجدون
هنا بهذه القاعه التابعه لمركز حزب الشعب
الجمهوري يعني المرشح الحزب مرشح
للمعارضه كمال كالشتار اوغلو ونتابع على
هذه الشاشه التي ترونها من خلف كما يتابع
مؤيدوه نتائج الانتخابات نرى بوضوح الان
بانه نقلا عن وكاله انكا التابعه
فان اردوغان حصد 47% فاصل تسعه من الاصوات
بينما حصد كمالكيشتار اوغلو
46.4% من الاصوات وسنان اوغان حصدى خمسه
فاصل ثلاثه بالمئه من الاصوات بعد قليل
ليال عندما تتغير وكاله الانباء على يسار
الشاشه
وتصبح اناضول نرى تغيرت الان انا دول نرى
بانه النسبه تغيرت
51%.42.8 بالمئه لكي وخمسه فاصل ثلاثه
بالمئه للسنان اوغان وبالتالي لا يمكن
الركوع بعد الى نتائج نهائيه لان النتائج
تتغير بحسب الوكاله التي تنقل عنها فكره
المعارضه تتحدث عن تقدم كالشتار اوغلو حتى
ان مختلف يعني
المسؤولين بالحزب الشعبي الجمهوري تحدثوا
باسهاب عن تقدم مرشحهم رئيس بلديه اسطنبول
مثلا وصفه بالسيد الرئيس كما ذكرتي في
الخبر ايضا رئيس بلديه انقره قال منذ قليل
باننا سنحسم هذه الجوله لصالح مرشحنا وعلى
الارجح لن نضطر الى جوله ثانيه وطبعا هذه
الانتقادات هذه التصريحات عذرا لقد
انتقادات من قبل
المسؤوليه حزب العداله والتنميه وبشكل عام
المسؤولين في حزب الامه الحاكم لانهم
اعتبروا تصريحات مثلا امام اوغلو بانها
تعدن على مؤسسات الدوله وبانه لا يحق له
ان يصل يصف المرشح الذي لم تحسم نتائجه
بعد بانه الرئيس وبالتالي حرب البيانات
التي والتصريحات التي شهدناها بالامس
تستمر اليوم ولكن حرب نتائج بين الطرفين
كريستيانو اسمحي لي ان انتقل الى انقره
ومراسل العربيه زيدان زنكلو زيدان ايضا من
انقره التي يعني هزم بها حزب العداله
والتنميه بالانتخابات الاخيره البلديه
الارقام حتى الساعه تشير الى تقدم
المعارضه هنا كيف هي الصوره واين اصبحنا
بالنتائج
نعم بالنسبه الى العاصمه التركيه انقره ثم
تواجد في مقر حزب العداله والتنميه هنا
المقر الرئيسي لحزب العداله والتنميه في
العاصمه التركيه انقره طبعا انصار الرئيس
التركي رجب طيب اردوغان وكما تشاهدون عبر
شاشه العربيه يحتفلون بالنتائج التي وردت
حتى الان يعني انا سانقل النتائج كما ذكرت
الزميله كريستيان هناك الارقام التي ترد
عبر وكاله الاناضول الحكوميه
وبحسب الاناضول نقلا عن الهيئه العليا
للانتخابات ان عدد الصناديق التي تم فرزها
بلغ
68.63
بالمحصله الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان
ما يزال متقدما
ب51.3% بينما منافسه بينهما منافس اردوكان
ان نتحدثون عن كمالك الجدار زعيم المعارضه
التركيه حصل على
[موسيقى]
حصل على
5.32% لكن كما ذكرت الزميله كريستيان
المعارضه تقول والان قبل قليل كان يتحدث
منصوريه واش رئيس بلديه انقره وايضا
اكرم امام اوبل رئيس بلديه اسطنبول منصور
كان يتحدث ان كل جدار اوغلو حصل على
47.42% بمعدل تصويت او عدد الناخبين الذين
صوتوا له حتى الان 11 مليون
و428 الف ناخذ بينما الرئيس التركي وهنا
نتحدث عن منصوريه واش البيانات التي
اعلنها قبل قليل حصل على
46.8
بمعدل تصويت ايضا بلغ او تجاوز 11 مليون
و200
[موسيقى]
8 اوافق 278 الف صوت هذا هذه الارقام التي
قال منصوري اواش ان ان هي الارقام التي
وصلتهم لحزب العداله والتنميه نعم حل يعني
نتحدث عن صوره مماثله عن اسطنبول فارق
كبير يعني بين الارقام التي تتحدث عنها
المعارضه والارقام الرسميه
نعم الارقام التي تتحدث عنها المعارضه او
زعماء المعارضه يتحدثون عن تقدم مرشحهم
وبالتالي نحن امام
حاله ربما استطيع القول ان اي من المرشحين
ونتحدث حاليا عن طرف الخاسر هو المعارضه
حتى الان لن يسلم بسهوله ولم يضطر بهذه
النتائج بسهوله ما لم تعلن بشكل رسمي من
الهواء العليا للانتخابات ايضا هنا
التعليقا على تصريحات
امام ومنصور وانا هنا استخدم الهاتف لانقل
كل التصريحات عمر شيليك المتحدث باسم حزب
العداله والتنميه الحاكم قال ان العديد من
المتحدثين وهنا يشير الى امام اوبلو
ومنصوريا واش يحاولون تفسير البيانات من
وجهه نظرهم الخاصه وقال ان بعضهم يعني حتى
الان
اعلن بشكل غير مبرر فوز مرشحهم بالنظر
وهنا يشير الى تصريحات امام اوبو والذي
وصف فيها
[موسيقى]
كل جدار بانه الرئيس الثالث عشر بتركيا او
الرئيس التركي طبعا
واضاف ايضا لا نستطيع ان نحكم من الان على
النتائج الانتخابات وانتقد الزعيم
المعارضه لقوله انهم في المقدمه في اشاره
الى التغريده التي نشرها وقال نحن متقدمون
غدا ساعود اليك ولكن لو سمحت ان ترفع صوتك
لان يعني الاغاني والاحتفاليه تشوش على
الصوت ساعود اليك بعد قليل الان مشاهدينا
الى غازي عنتاب ومفرد العربيه عبد القادر
خربوش عبد القادر عندما نقول غازي عنتاب
نقول المناطق المنكوبه اثرى الزلزال
الارقام الاوليه تشير الى تقدم اردوغان ما
هي التحديثات لديك من هناك
بالفعل هنا لا توجد اصوات صخب او احتفالات
على الاقل حيث اقف باصلاحيه وهي من بين
البلدات التابعه لغازي عنتاب المتضرره
كثيرا جراء الزلزال اخر تحديثات وفق وكاله
الاناضول التي نتابعها بين الفينه والاخرى
ارتفعت نسبه الصناديق التي تم فرزها الى
الحين حيث بلغت
67.5
ويتقدم دائما رجب طيب اردوغان بنسبه
51.2% على نظيره كنجدار اوغلو الذي يحقق
نوعا ما تقدما مع كل تحديد بحسب الارقام
التي تنشرها وكاله الاناضول حيث بلغت نسبه
حصوله على الاصوات ثلاثه واربعين في المئه
يعني منذ حوالي 20 او الى نصف ساعه كل
تحديد نلاحظ ان اردوغان لا يتقدم كثيرا
وانما
تقدما ولو بطيئا ما يؤشر الى ربما ان تتجه
النتيجه الى الحسم بجوله ثانيه عبد القادر
وتصريحات بعض المراقبين بان هذه النتائج
قد تحسب في الجوله الاولى هل لديك اي
تحديثات عن ارقام الاقتراع بهذه المناطق
خصوصا ان هناك يعني كان هناك تعويل من قبل
المعارضه على المتضررين الزلزال بالتصويت
ضد اردوغان ولكن هناك العديد نتحدث عن
الملايين الذين نزحوا من هذه المناطق
وبالتالي هناك الكثيرين الذين لم يستطيعوا
اصلا التصويت هل لديك اي تحديثات حول
ارقام يعني التصويت الى الى اي
مدى وصلت
بالفعل المناطق الزلزال حيث كنت قبل ان
اصل الى اصلاحيه كنت فيها طاي المدينه
الاكثر تضررا من الزلزال رغم الدمار
المحيط بكل هذه المدينه الا ان نسبه
الاقبال على المشاركه في الانتخابات كانت
كبيره وعاليه جدا بلغت ثلاثه وثمانين
فاصله ثلاثه في المئه يعني عدد المسجلين
الناخبين كان يبلغ مليون واثنين الف ناخذ
بهذه الولايه وتم يعني قدموا من مختلف
الولايات وشاركوا في هذه الانتخابات
النتائج الاوليه لحد الان وفق الاناضول
بهاتاي تحديدا
رجحت الى طيب رجب اردوغان رغم ان هذه
المدينه معروف عنها انها دائما ما تصوت
للمعارضه الى ان لحد الان ووفق هذه
النتائج الاوليه لصناديق الفرز
9.59,3 التي تم فرزها لحد الان ترشح الكفه
لرجب طيب اردوغان
ب51.8 مقابل 44
اما عن غازي عنتاب فهي مدينه معروف عنها
بانها تصوت للعداله والتنميه اي لرجب طيب
اردوغان حيث تم تسجيل لحد الان نسبه
هو متقدم باكثر من 60% على الاقل من خلال
اخر تحديث لهذه الارقام التي تنشرها وكاله
الاناضول دون الحديث عن ما تنشره المعارضه
من ارقام ومن مصادرها هي الاخرى لحد الان
هناك حرب وهناك تصريحات وتصريحات مضاده
حول من يتقدم عن الاخر لكن كل هذا سيحسم
بعد تقريبا حوالي ساعه من الان ان استمرت
عمليه الفرز بهاته الوتيره المتسارعه
وسيتم الاعلان عما تقدم عن الاخر وعن من
سيكون الرئيس الثالث عشر لتركيا في هذا
الاستحقاق الانتخابي الهام جدا الذي جاء
بعد
كارثه الزلزال وجاء على انقاذ ايضا متاعب
اقتصاديه تعيشها تركيا وعن يعني مطالب
وامال جيل جديد بلغ عدد الناخبين فيه اكثر
من اربعه ملايين شاب ينتخ لاول مره لم
يعرفوا حاكما لبلدهم غير رجب طيب اردوغان
كانت هناك كثير من التحليلات والتاويلات
بشان هذه الفئه الناخبه تحديدا وايضا
الفئه الناخبه لمناطق الزلزال وضحايا
الزلزال بانها قد تحدث الفارق وتكون عنصر
حسم لهذه العمليه الانتخابيه لكن على
الارض اليوم شاهدنا غير ذلك وابرز ما
شاهدناه وما يعني عايشناه هو والتقارب بين
المرشحين البارزين لهاته الانتخابات
الرئاسيه
لعبد القادر ان اعود الى اسطنبول ومفردات
العربيه كريستيانو بيسري كريستيانو قبل ان
اعود اليك ساشير مشاهدينا الى هذه النتائج
التي تظهر الان على الشاشه
اردوغان
51.33%
42.85% ان نتحدث هنا عن فرز 65.
اذا هذه
الارقام الاوليه الان بحسب وكاله الاناضول
يفيدني الزملاء بان كالجدار اوغلو يتقدم
على اردوغان اذا النسب يعني تتارجح بين
الدقيقه والاخرى اعود اليك كريستيانو
كريستيانو يعني الصوره من اسطنبول خصوصا
ان اسطنبول تمثل يعني هي الاهميه الكبرى
اليوم بهذه الانتخابات كيف هي صوره من
هناك
يمكن يعني ان نجمل هذا النهار ليال بما
انك تتحدثي عن اسطنبول تحديدا بان الثقل
الانتخابي الاساسي هو هنا في اسطنبول فهي
تعد احد عشر مليون ناخب ويقال بان من يفوز
في اسطنبول عاده يفوز في الانتخابات ولذلك
قرر ان يقترع
قرر ان يقتر في اسطنبول ومن ثم فيما بعد
توجه الى انقره لمتابعه نتائج الفرز الان
بما انك تتحدث ايضا عن النتائج هي تتغير
بحسب وكاله انقى فان اردوغان 48% نسبته
هذا نتحدث عن فرز 60% من الاصوات الان
تغيرت بحسب وكاله الاناضول تم فرز 69% من
الاصوات والاردوغان الان يحقق نسبه 51%
مقابل 43
حقيقه الكل متفاجئ ليال بالنسبه التي حصل
عليها سنان اوغان هي ضعف النسبه التي نسبه
الاصوات التي كان من المتوقع ان يحصل
عليها هو الذي يمثل حزب اجدادنا حزب يميني
قومي متطرف يدعو الى التخلص البلاد من كل
اللاجئين والمهاجرين للحفاظ على الهويه
القوميه لتركيا وبالتالي هذا مؤشر على
مزاج الشارع التركي ان يعطي هذه النسبه
غير المتوقعه من الاصوات لمرشح يمثل هذه
الطروحات ويقال بانه كلما علت نسبه سنان
اوغان فانه من المتوقع ان تذهب الانتخابات
الى جوله ثانيه ليتمكن احد المرشحين
الاساسيين من حسمها
كريستيانو اسمحي لي ان اعود الى انقره
وزيدان زنكلو زيدان يعني حتى الساعه تقدم
اردوغان على اوغلو هل من تحديثات حول
الارقام في انقره
نعم الان وصلت للارقام التي نشرتها وكاله
النضول نقدا عن الهيئه العليا للانتخابات
فيما يخص انقره فيما يخص انقره ساحاول رفع
صوتي قدر الامكان تم فرز حوالي اكثر من 65
او بالضبط 65.7 من صناديق الاقتراع نسبه
المشاركه في الانتخابات في انقره بلغت حتى
الان
90.81 في المئه حتى الان بعد فوز اكثر من
65% من الصناديق الرئيس التركي لجلب طيب
اردوغان يتقدم ب
48.13% في انقره مرشح المعارضه وتحالف
الامه والطاوله السداسيه كمال كل جدار
اوكلوا
حصل على
44.95 من اصوات الناخبين في انقره بينما
المرشح الثالث سنان اوغان حصل على 6.51 في
المئه بالنسبه الى عدد الاصوات حتى الان
اردوغان حصل على مليون و1 الف او اكثر من
مليون
و185 الف بالنسبه
لتجاوز عدد اصوات مليون ومئه الف في انقره
بالنسبه الى سنان اوغان حصل على اكثر من
160 الف صوت هذه هي النتائج في انقره حتى
الان وكما قلت تم فرز اكثر من 65% تقريبا
نقترب من 66% من نسبه الاصوات التي تم
فرزها في العاصمه التركيه انقره
شكرا لكم مراسلي العربيه كريستيانو بيسر
من اسطنبول زيدان لما انقره ومن غازي
عنتاب عبد القادر خربوش مشاهدينا ساعود
واذكر بالنتائج التي يعني صدرت حتى الان
51 بالمئه فاصله 14% لاردوغان
و43.5
لاوغلو حسب النتائج الاوليه على واقع
انتظار صدور النتائج النهائيه في تركيا
سنستعرض معكم مشاهدينا السيناريو الابرز
في حال كسب احد الطرفين المتنافسين
الرئاسه وخسر في البرلمان الفوز بالرئاسه
بعيدا عن البرلمان سيكون غير مكتمل وناقص
وعلى سبيل المثال في حال فاز اردوغان
بالرئاسه وخسر الاغلبيه في البرلمان هذا
يعني انه سيواجه صعوبه كبيره في اداره
البلاد وفق الخبراء لماذا لانه لا اداره
البلاد بموجد مراسيم رئاسيه وهناك حاجه
طبعا للتعامل بين السلطه التنفيذيه
والسلطه التشريعيه لاقرار القوانين
والمشاريع اما اذا تعاكست نتائج
الانتخابات اي الرئاسه عن البرلمان فستدخل
هنا تركيا في ازمه سياسيه صعبه وربما
ستؤدي الى انتخابات مبكره عامه بالعموم
طبعا في المستقبل لاجل ذلك مشاهدينا على
اي تحالف سواء كان المعارضه او الحزب
الحاكم ان يتمكن من الفوز بالانتخابات
بشقيها اي البرلمانيه والرئاسيه وفقا طبعا
لخبراء اشياء ان التركي هنا ايضا يجب
التوقف عند نقطه مهمه جدا وهي ان من بين
المرشحين الثلاثه في السباق الرئاسي وحده
اردوغان يؤكد ان تركيا يجب ان يحكمها نظام
رئاسي ولتغيير طريقه حكم البلاد يحتاج
طبعا الدستور الى التعديل وللقيام بذلك
يجب ان يصوت ثلثاء النواب اي 400 في
البرلمان بنعم من اصل 600 وهنا لابد من
الاشاره الا ان عدد الاحزاب المشاركه في
الانتخابات البرلمانيه يبلغ 26 حزبا
وتنخرط الصغيره منها في تحالفات مع
الاحزاب الكبيره
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا التاسع مستمره وفيها بعد قليل
لاول مره منذ 12 عاما وفد سوري يشارك في
الاجتماعات التحضيريه للجامعه العربيه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد كشف برلماني ايراني عن
وجود ترتيبات لعقد لقاء بين الرئيسين
الايراني ابراهيم رئيسي والمصري عبد
الفتاح السيسي بعد الانتهاء من اعاده
افتتاح سفرتي البلدين كما قررت السلطات
المصريه اطلاق مجموعه من التيسيرات للسياح
الاجانب لزياره طبعا اراضيها بينهم
الايرانيون قبل ذلك عبر وزير الخارجيه
الايراني حسين امير عبد الله عن امله في
ان تشهد العلاقات الايرانيه المصريه
انفتاحا جديا
القطيعه المصريه الايرانيه بدات عام 1980
بعد عام من الاطاحه بالشاه محمد رضا بهلوي
اسباب القطيعه ايران تحججت بتوقيع مصر
اتفاقيه السلام مع اسرائيل واستضافه شاه
ايران محمد رضا بهلوي
وبالنسبه لمصر في ايران اطلقت اسم خالد
الاسلامبولي المتهم باغتيال السادات على
احد شوارع طهران ورفعت جداريه ضخمه تحمل
صورته
محاولات التقارب عام 2003 الرئيس المصري
حسني مبارك يلتقي نظيره الايراني محمد
خاتمي على هامش قمه دوليه في جنيب
عام 2012 زياره الرئيس المصري محمد مرسي
لطهران لحضور فعاليات قمه دول عدم
الانحياز
عام 2013 الرئيس الايراني محمود احمد نجاه
في القاهره لحضور قمه منظمه التعاون
الاسلامي
وفي عام 2022 الرئيس المصري عبد الفتاح
السيسي التقى في بغداد بوزير خارجيه ايران
حسين امير عبدالله هيان
وفي عام 2023 وزير خارجيه ايران يشير الى
مباحثات لتحقيق التقارب بين القاهره
وطهران وبرلماني ايراني يؤكد الاتفاق على
اعاده فتح السفارتين بين البلدين قريبا
ينضم الينا مشاهدينا من القاهره الدكتور
محمد الزيات مستشار المركز المصري للفكر
والدراسات الاستراتيجيه دكتور يعني تقارب
مصري ايراني تدريجي بوساطه عراقيه شرط
طبعا موضوع الدعم الايراني للجماعات
المسلحه في المنطقه التدخل في الدول
المجاوره والدول العربيه كل هذا التقارب
التدريجي بعد مسار الانفتاح الخليجي
العربي الايراني كيف سيتحقق
يعني دعيني اشير الى عدد من الملاحظات
الاوليه الحديث الذي ذكره البرلماني
الايراني اعتقد انه غير صحيح لانه
وزير الخارجيه الايراني منذ عده شهور تحدث
عن اتصالات
ومباحثات تتم بواسطه عراقيه ورد وزير
الخارجيه المصري عليها بانه لا توجد اي
اتصالات بين وفوده رسميه مصريه وايرانيه
النقطه الثانيه الحديث عن عدد افتتاح
السفاره حديث غريب لان هناك سفاره مفتوحه
بالفعل في البلدين وهناك بعثه برعايه
مصالح يرقصها دبلوماسي كبير ومستمره ولم
تغلق يعني والحوار الذي يجري كما جاء على
لسان وزير خارجيه بين بعثتي رئيس رعايه
المصالح في البلدين اما الحديث عن ترتيب
لقاء للرئيس عبد الفتاح السيسي مع رئيس
الايراني فاعتقد انه سابق لاوانه بصوره
كبيره يعني دعينا نتحدث في البدايه اذا
كان هناك توجه لتطوير علاقات ان يعني عقد
لقاء ما بين وزيره خارجيه البلدين لكن ان
ان يتوج وان تتوج العلاقات اذا نجحت وحدثت
تقارب يتم اللقاء الرئيسيين لان هناك ما
زالت ملفات فائكه بين البلدين لم تبحث ولا
اعتقد الاتصالات اذا كانت اتصالات شاركت
فيها وفود امنيه فاعتقد ان هناك اجنده
خاصه بقضايا امنيه ربما كانت ترغب مصر في
مناقشتها اولا واثبات حسن النوايا
الايرانيه تجاهها
الملفات الاساسيه هي ملفات امنيه سياسيه
بامتياز ما الشروط التي تضعها القاهره
اليوم لهذا التقارب
يعني فيما يتعلق بالامن او الملفات
الامنيه هناك استضافه ايرانيه لعدد من
قيادات تنظيم القاعده التاريخيه الموجوده
هناك وهناك حديث عن ان بعض العناصر
التابعه للقاعده والتي تتحرك ما بين ايران
وافغانستان او مناطق اخرى والحديث هنا
والتشاور سيكون هل لدى ايران معلومات عن
عناصر مصريه موجوده هناك او اتصالات بينها
وبين التنظيمات الارهابيه التي تهدد الامن
المصري هذه نقطه اما فيما يتعلق بالملفات
السياسيه فهناك قضايا كثيره فيها اشتباك
ما بين البلدين الموقف التموضع الايراني
على مستوى المنطقه باكملها والذي يعتبر
يسحب من المساحات المتاحه للحركه المصريه
الاقليميه وكذلك الانخراط الايراني في
ملفات او في دول تعتبرها مصر مهمه بالنسبه
للامن القومي المصري كما الحل في سوريا
وفي لبنان كما ان
محاوله التمركز العسكري الايراني في البحر
الاحمر يمس الامن القومي المصري بصوره
كبيره هذه كلها قضايا لا اعتقد انها تبحث
على مستوى خبراء او مستوى في انبعثه رعايه
مصالح اذا ما كان المقصود ان تكون هناك
علاقات يعني قويه بين البلدين
بين الجانب
المصري كان يعني شرط الاساسي اعاده تعريف
واعاده يعني ضبط للتمدد الايراني داخل
المنطقه ما هي الملفات المسلمه بعد هذا
التقارب التي هناك يعني اتفاق تام بين
القاهره
وطهران عليها
هي نفس القضايا التي طرحت في اللقاء في
عند قرار الاتفاق
بين المملكه العربيه السعوديه وما بين
ايران هي نفس القضايا بالتحديد الوجود
الايراني في سوريا والذي اعتبر يعني لو
لاحظنا قرار مجلس الجامعه واشتراطه خروج
القوات الاجنبيه على على اختلافها من
سوريا هذه قضيه من بينها الوجود الايراني
والمريشيات التابعه له اعتقد ان هذا ملف
ايضا تناقشه مصر التي تعلن فيما يتعلق
بالازمه السوريه مبادئ محدده الحفاظ على
تماسك الدوله المصريه
ومواجهه الارهاب وخروج جميع القوات
الاجنبيه هناك هذه قضيه يعني ليست قضيه
ثنائيه فقط ولكن قضيه عامه طرحت من
المملكه العربيه السعوديه لدوله الامارات
وما الدول الاخرى هذه قضيه اولى
انتشار الميليشيات التابعه لايران
الموجوده في تلك المنطقه والتي تمارس
ادوارا غريبه فيما يتعلق بمواقفها من
قضايا اخرى اعتقد هذه الميليشيات مطالبه
بالخروج من داخل سوريا وهي ايضا مطالبه
بالخروج كمطلب مصري على اعتبار الاهميه
التي تمثلها سوريا ليس فقط بالنسبه لمصر
ولكن بالنسبه الاقليم وبالتالي نحن نتحدث
عن استكمال للمشاورات التي اصلا بدات بهذه
الملفات شكرا لك دكتور محمد الزيات مستشار
المركز المصري للفكر والدراسات
الاستراتيجيه
[موسيقى]
اسبوع خامس من الاقتتال العسكري يشهده
السودان فلا جديد سوى اصوات الانفجارات
والقصف والمعارك بين كل من الجيش وقوات
الدعم السريع نبدا ميدانيه مشاهدينا حيث
افادت مصادر العربيه بتجدد الاشتباكات
وسماع صوت الانفجارات في العاصمه الخرطوم
حيث استخدم الجيش الطائرات الحربيه لقصف
مواقع الدعم السريع فيما اعلنت طبعا الامم
المتحده هنا ارتفاع عدد القتلى قتل
الاشتباكات الى حوالي 680 قتيلا كما
تواصلت الاشتباكات بالاسلحه الثقيله نتحدث
هنا بمدينه الجنينه غربي دارفور بعدما
تصدت قوات الجيش لهجوم من الدعم السريع في
ثلاث اتجاهات على الجنينه اما على صعيد
المبادرات والمباحثات الجاريه في جده التي
تستانف اليوم فيها الجوله الثانيه التي
تتركز حول كيفيه تنفيذ خطط ايصال
المساعدات الانسانيه
طبعا القوات من المناطق الميدانيه وفق ما
ذكرت هنا رويترز عن مصدر دبلوماسي سعودي
ومع تجدد الاشتباكات مددت سلطه الطيران
المدني في السودان اغلاق المجال الجوي
امام حركه الطيران حتى نهايه الشهر الجاري
بدوره هنا حذر حزب
المؤتمر السوداني من انزلاق البلاد الى
حرب الاهليه شامله مع غياب اجهزه الدوله
وداعا الى التنفيذ الفوري لاعلان جده الذي
وقعه ممثل الجيش والدعم السريع مؤخرا
تستسلم من ذلك مشاهدينا رحلات المساعدات
الانسانيه كما اصبح معلوم ورحلات الاجلاء
بعد الحصول على تصريح من قبل الجهات
المختصه والمسؤوله هي عن تلك العمليات
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا اعود الى نتائج الانتخابات
التركيه والتحديد حتى الساعه اردوغان
50.91.91 بالمئه حتى هذه الساعه
43.28 بالمئه ايضا حتى هذه الساعه كما
نتابع على الشاشه فرز حتى الساعه
33.08 من اجمالي الاصوات في تركيا في
المحافظات التركيه اذا حتى الساعه اكثر من
خمسين بالمئه لاردوغان 43 بالمئه فاصله
28% لاجله ونسبه الفرز وصلت الى
73.8
باجماليه نتائج الفرز التركيه اذن مازلنا
يعني نتابع الفرز الذي ما زال مستمر حتى
الساعه لمعرفه النتائج النهائيه وسنعود
بعد قليل للزملاء الم في تركيا
باستكمال ملف الخرطوم ينضم الينا من
السودان من الخرطوم شهد نادر الصحافي من
مكتب العربيه شاهد يعني بعد الاتفاق
والجوله الاولى من المباحثات في جده والتي
تعتبر طبعها انساني بحث في المرحله الاولى
كيف هي صوره من هناك
ويعني عمليات الاجلاء المساعدات الانسانيه
وكل ما الى هنالك لو سمحت
مرحب لا جديد في المشهد ذات الطيران بدا
اليوم تحليقه منذ صباح الباكر عده ضربات
في عده اتجاهات في جنوب ام درمان في مدينه
الخرطوم وكذلك في مدينه الخرطوم بحري
اشتباكات بالاسلحه الخفيفه والثقيله كذلك
في جنوب مدينه ام درمان ادخنه كانت تتصاعد
منتصف نهار اليوم من عده نقاط من سوق ام
درمان وكذلك من جنوب المدينه علمنا بان
اشتباكات تدور الان في بعض المناطق في
مدينه
الخرطوم هذا هو المشهد عسكريا يمكن القول
بانه لا جديد فيه انسانيا وما الى ذلك
تتفاقم الاوضاع الانسانيه يوما بعد يوم
برقم التحسن برقم الجهود الرسميه والشعبيه
في مايل المستشفيات في ميل المراكز
الاصيحيه وما الى ذلك ولكن الوضع يحتاج
لتدخل في انتظار فتح المسارات الامنه بحسب
نقابه اطباء للسودان ان كل المستشفيات
بحسب ما قره اعلان الجده التي ينتظر او
يفترض اخلائها
ليس فيها حتى الان جديد معتدال القوات
متواجده فيها ما تزال المسارات
غير متاحه حتى يتمكن الفرق الطبيه واطقم
الطوارئ من النزول
مباشره اعمالهم وتوفير الاحتياجات
المطلوبه
من الخرطوم
مشاهدينا التاسعه مستمره وفيها بعد قليل
فيضانات في الصومال تشرد اكثر من 200 الف
شخص وتقتل اكثر من 20 اخرين
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد مشاهدينا نعود لمتابعه
النتائج الانتخابات التركيه كما نتابع هنا
على الشاشه اردوغان حصد حتى الساعه
50.76 بالمئه اوغلو
43.43
ونتحدث هنا عن نسبه تصويت او نسبه فرز
وصلت الى
74.77 اذا هذه هي النتائج الاوليه حتى
الساعه وهذه هي التحديثات حتى الساعه
ساعود الى شبكه مراسله العربيه بعد قليل
[موسيقى]
اعود الى انقره ومراسل العربيه زيدان
زنكلو زيدان مع هذه التحديثات التي
ذكرناها والتي ما زالت تشير الى تقدم
اردوغان كيف هي الصوره من انقره بين يعني
تحالف الشعب وتحالف الامه من هناك
نعم لا شك ان الارقام تتغير باستمرار بلغت
اخر احصائيه وصلتنا بعد ان
قرات الخبر ليال تم فرز اكثر من على وجه
التحديد
78.93% من الاصوات في عموم تركيا الرئيس
التركي رجب طيب اردوغان لا يزال متقدما
بخمسين فاصله
47% كل جدار اوكلو زعيم المعارضه 43
الارقام تتحدث
43.44
بينما سنان اوغان حصل على
5.33
ساعرج سريعا على الانتخابات او عفوا على
نتائج الانتخابات البرلمانيه فيما يخص
الانتخابات البرلمانيه تم فرز
64,48% من مجمل الصناديق في عموم تركيا
تحالف الشعب الذي يقوده اردوغان حصل على
52% بمعدل 327 مقعد في البرلمان حتى هذه
اللحظه تحالف الامه المعارض حصل على
33.45
طبعا حزب او تحالف الاجداد حصل على واحد
فاصله 70% ايضا تحالف العمل والحريه الذي
يقوده حزب الشعوب الديمقراطي الكردي حصل
على
9,9% تقريبا هذه هي الارقام في عموم تركيا
لكن فيما يخص العاصمه التركيه انقر حيث
نتواجد الان نحن نتحدث عن الارقام الرسميه
التي تنشرها وكاله الاناضول الرسميه ليال
تم فرز
74.4% من مجمل الصناديق طبعا المشاركه في
انقره بلغت
90,33% الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان
متقدما ب
47.73% حصل مليون
و339
الف صوت و194 صوت مرشح المعارضه كمال
كالجدار اوبلو حصل على
45.40% بمعدل او بواقع مليون ومئتين
واربعه وسبعين الف صوت في انقره سنان
اوغان مرشح تحالف اجداد حصل على سته فاصله
48% بمعدل اصوات
181,800 صوت هذه هي مجمل حصيله العاصمه
التركيه انقره بالعموم قبل قليل تم ابلاغ
الصحفيين المتواجدين هنا في مقر حزب
العداله والتنميه في انقره بان مسؤول من
حزب العداله والتنميه سيلقي كلمه بعد قليل
هنا للانصار المحتشدين في هذا الميدان
انصار الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان تقريبا
الساحه التي تقابل او الساحه التي تتبع
لحزب العداله والتنميه تقريبا قد امتلات
سوى هذا هذه المنطقه التي نقف فيها الان
حتى الان لم تمتلئ بشكل كامل لكن في
المجمل بقيه اطراف هذه الساحه قد امتلات
بالكامل بانصار الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان وهم يحتفلون قبل قليل مع اغاني
المرشح الرئاسي طبعا او الرئيس الحالي رجب
طيب اردوغان وهتافات تدعم الرئيس الذي
يتواجد هنا في انقره طبعا فيما يخص
المعارضه التركيه الانباء تتحدث
والزميل طهر بركه من امام مقر حزب العداله
والتنميه طاهر كيف هي الصوره من هناك وكيف
هي تحديثات الارقام من انقره خصوصا ان
المعارضه تتحدث عن عفوا من اسطنبول تتحدث
عن تقدمها باسطنبول
اهلا ليال اهلا بالمشاهدين دعني دعيني
احيلك مباشره الى هذه الشاشه العملاقه من
خلفي في مقر حزب العداله والتنميه الرئيس
في اسطنبول التي تعرض الارقام اولا باول
بعد فرز سبعه وسبعين بالمئه فاصل صفر خمسه
من الاصوات في الانتخابات الرئاسيه
77.05
نتحدث عن
50.68 بالمئه للرئيس اردوغان
و43.52
اما المرشح الثالث
على خمسه.3 واحد بالمئه الان ما يقال لهنا
بانه كلما زادت ارقام سنان اوغان كلما
زادت الاحتمالات للذهاب الى دوره ثانيه
الى جوله ثانيه في الثامن والعشرين من
مايو كنا نلاحظ هذه الارقام عند الرئيس
اردوغان في بدايات الفرز كانت اعلى من ذلك
كان اقل ولكن كلما زادت نسب التصويت الفرز
عفوا كلما خفت نسبه الرئيس اردوغان وعلت
او ثبتت الى حد ما في بعض الاحيان نسبه
في هذه الحاله الان نصل بعد فرد 77% من
الاصوات الى 50% فاصل سته ثمانيه تفضلي
ظاهره الاوليه اصبحنا نتحدث عن احتماليه
الذهاب الى جوله اعاده ما هي الارقام اذا
سمحت ان نشرح للمشاهدين التي يمكن القول
بختام هذه الجوله باننا ذاهبين الى جوله
اعاده كيف هي صوره الارقام التي تشير الى
جوله اعاده
الارقام التي تشير الى جوله اعاده في
الانتخابات الرئاسيه بكل بساطه هي اقل من
50 زائد واحد من لا يتمكن من الحصول على
خمسين زائد واحد لا يمكنه العبور او الفوز
وبالتالي يجب عليها ان يخوض جوله اعاده مع
الطرف الاخر الذي حصل على اكبر نسبه اصوات
وفي هذه الحاله نتحدث هنا عن اردوغان وعن
اذا لم يحصل احدهما على 50 زائدا واحدا
سنذهب الى جوله اعاده محدده سلفا في 28 من
مايو ان لم يفز فائز بالخمسين زائد واحد
من الجوله الاولى اما في الانتخابات
البرلمانيه فيجب على الفائز ان يحوز على
سبعه بالمئه ان يتخطى السبعه بالمئه ان
كان منفردا او اذا على صعيد التحالف اذا
كان منفردا يجب ان يتخطا 7% او اذا كانت
عده احزاب متحالفه فيحسب تحسب السبعه
بالمئه للتحالف ككل اما على صعيد
الانتخابات العامه اي البر الان يمكن ان
نشير وفقا لاخر الارقام بعد فرز
64.1% من الصناديق بتقدم تحالف الجمهور
الذي يتزعمه حزب العداله والتنميه برئاسه
اردوغان او بزعامته
ب51.9% مقابل
33.6 بالمئه لتحالف الامه الفارق كبير
لصالح تحالف الجمهور الذي يضم حزب العداله
والتنميه الحركه القوميه
الرفاه من جديد بزعامه فاتح حربكان
والاتحاد الكبير اما تحالف الامه بزعامه
كريتشار اوغلوفا لي يشمل على الشعب
الجمهوري الذي يتراسه وحسب الجيد برئاسه
ميرال اكشنر اما التحالف الاخر المعارض
الذي يضم اليسار الاخضر او حزب الشعوب
الديمقراطي كما نعرف فحاز على 9.1 بالمئه
وهو يدعم كريتش ولكنه غير متحالف معه في
الانتخابات البرلمانيه اذا الارقام
متباعده في البرلم حتى الان وفقا للصناديق
التي تم فرزها وهي
64% نحصل على
51.9% لتحالف الجمهور الارقام لا تزال
تتحدث نتحدث عن 78 بالمئه اذا الان في
الرئاسيات ليال عاد زاد العدد في بقر حزب
العداله والتنميه كما تشاهدين امامك بعد
فرد 78 بالمئه اكثر بقليل الرئيس اردوغان
يحصل على
50.60 بالمئه ان استمر هذا الرقم في
النزول وظلك ايضا عند رقمه في اوائل
الاربعينات فنحن سنكون ذاهبين الى جوله
اعاده الا اذا حصلت مفاجات في الارقام
المتبقيه حتى المئه بالمئه
كان
هناك اساسيين المدن المتارجحه
والجيل الجديد او الجيل زاد كما تسمونه
هذين العاملين حتى الساعه لجانب اي يعني
تحالف لاعبات اذا كان هناك اي تحديثات حول
الارقى
من الصعب ومن المبكر بمكان ان تحدد هذه
النسب فيما يتعلق باين ذهبت الرصد كله
الان في من الاعلاميين ومن يعني المسؤولين
في حزب العداله والتنميه في هذا المقر
للارقام بشكل عام لانه التحديث اول باول
والفرز سريع جدا ليال يعني منذ السابعه
وحتى العاشره الان يعملوا في في ثلاث
ساعات النتيجه وصلت الى ثمانيه وسبعين
بالمئه فرزا
للرئاسيات واكثر من 65 نحو 66%
للبرلمانيات فبالتالي نحن يعني يلزمنا بعض
الوقت لكي نحدد ماذا حصل تحديدا في تلك
المدن لعلها تبرز مفاجات الرقم العام
يعطينا صوره عامه عامه حصل بين يعني عن
النسب التي حصل عليها الرجلان او التي حصل
عليها المرشحون لبر
ولكن ان نحدد في كل مدينه ماذا حصل
بانتظار ان ينتهي الفرز لعل النتيجه تحدث
فارقا لاحقا او تتغير ولعل المزيد من
الارقام تصدر فيما يتعلق بالشباب في
الساعات والايام المقبله ولكن بدون شك
الشباب كان عنصرا مهما وحاسما ومرجحا في
هذه الانتخابات مع وجود اكثر من خمسه
ملايين شاب ينتخبون للمره الاولى اضافه
الى عوامل اخيره يعني عوامل كثيره اخرى
كنا رصدناها في خلال الحملات الانتخابيه
وفي هذا اليوم من الاكثر تاثيرا في هذه
الانتخابات
طاهر يقول بان من يربح
اسطنبول ايضا
على اسطنبول التي تمثل ثقل الانتخابي كبير
المعارضه تقول الان بانها متقدمه في
اسطنبول الصوره من مركز حزب العداله
والتنميه ليس بالاجمال انما باسطنبول
تحديدا هل من ارقام محدثه لو سمحت
في مقر حزب العداله والتنميه في الخارج
يحتفلون
يغنون يعني يريدون ان يبرزوا انهم جاهزون
لاعلان الفوز كما كان يتحدث زميل زيدان من
قبل عن الوضع في انقره هو الحال نفسه في
مقر حزب العداله والتنميه في الخارج
والعلو يكون عندنا بعض الرسائل من الخارج
في خلال هذه الليله في الحالتين يعني في
حاله الفوز او في حاله الخساره لنقف على
راي مناصرهم فيما يتعلق باخر الارقام هم
يقولون انهم الفائزون يعني يتبادلون
الاتهامات فيما يتعلق باعلان الارقام
المعارضه من جهتها تقول ان الارقام يعني
لا يجب ان تعلن الان من قبل وكاله
الاناضول الرسميه نعم معك
طاهر انا لو
سمحت حقا مشاهدينا ساعود مجددا الى انقره
التي ايضا تمثل ساقه الانتخاب مع زيدان
زنكلو زيدان هل من تحديثات حول الارقام
وكيف هي الصوره من هناك
[موسيقى]
نعم الصوت التقطع لكن على ما اعتقد ان
السؤال كان الصوت يتقطع لكن على ما اظن ان
السؤال كان عن التحديثات الان اخر
التحديثات تشير الى انه تم فرز اكثر من
واحد وثمانين فاصله 44% من مجمل الصناديق
في عموم تركيا الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان ما زال يتقدم بخمسين فاصله 58%
الان ايضا تحدثت النسبه بلغت نسبه الفرز
82.69
اردوغان يتقدم بخمسين فاصله 48% تشاهدين
في كل دقيقه
كمال جدار اوغلو
على ما يبدو اننا فقدنا الاتصال بالزميل
زيدان زنك لمشاهدينا ساعود واشير طبعا الى
النتائج اردوغان 50.6% حتى الساعه
43.6 بالمئه وايضا
5.31 بالمئه ختام التاسعه اخبار العربيه
مستمره الان وتغطيه الانتخابات تركيا
مستمره الان الى 360 مع الزميله راويه
راويه تفضلي طبعا الانتخابات التركيه هي
الاساس الليله صحيح هي العنوان الابرز
وسنتابع النتائج وعمليات الفارس مع شبكه
مراسلي تفضل
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات